hello
i you just have to keep so it's ten
o'clock and i'm going to start the um
subcommittee work session on house bill
so the objective of this work session is
to determine based on the input that we
had during the hearings whether or not
this bill is worthy of
further um legislation
right
so the
objection that we had
from
[Music]
first you don't succeed try something
else i know
so um
the objection that we had to this bill
originally was that
the use of licensing for law enforcement
was
an issue
that the committee
objected to
and there were many um
suggestions made to address that
and i think that the testimony from
the city of derry
and other
towns who had said who had sent
letters to the committee
enforced the need of this
from a from a law enforcement standpoint
but the licensing board is not a
policing
organization
so
knowing that
have you
have you had any thoughts on that i'm
asking
um miss coppola to see to for comment or
either one of you or anybody from oplc
to comment on that
so thank you representative um
sorry
um thank you um
i agree the licensing board is not
responsible for law enforcement and that
that was an issue i think our main
concern is
um health and safety from more of a
hygiene aspect and it sort of became
once law enforcement became part of the
issue
it kind of went in that direction um but
our
focus really is more on health and
safety and welfare of the public and
it's more
you know hygiene issues that sanitary
issues similar to you know barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics where those
are some of the things that are
inspected
um
so we would
it makes sense for the focus to stay
there and and not on law enforcement
because i agree that's not what the
board
function is
so do you have any recommendations of
what future legislation would look like
how would we amend this to address that
i think it could be amended
i think most of the language um does
focus more on sanitary conditions
hygiene those types of concerns
i think it may have been the addition
of you know including prostitution human
trafficking that
made this a little bit more of a law
enforcement type
issue so those things could certainly be
removed
um
you know it does talk about any sexually
related crime i don't know that it then
needs to be
um
more specific to include prostitution
and human trafficking i think those
things necessarily fall within
um any any crime involving violence
inflicted on a person that type of thing
um
because any time one of our inspectors
goes in to inspect for sanitary
conditions for example um
you know if our barber and cosmetology
and aesthetics
inspectors go in to inspect and they see
evidence of a crime they can
certainly report that to law enforcement
um even if they're not looking for it
question
so
as i understand it from
the years i've been working with uh
your office and your predecessors uh one
of your functions is clearly uh
his
enforcement of the statute
uh and whether licensing is being
observed and so forth and since
these illegal establishments
do not meet the necessary criteria
for massage therapeutic massage
administration
and one of the functions of your
inspectors as i understand it is to find
out whether
the people in the establishment are
licensed or not
correct
yes correct okay so if they're not
licensed because they're not performing
therapeutic massage they're not
qualified to be licensed
and they cannot legitimately be licensed
then they are operating illegally would
you agree
if i unders
i'm not certain i understand the
question if they
hold themselves out as a massage
establishment
and we were allowed to have inspectors
go in to inspect
then they would determine whether anyone
was licensed
correct
and since these people are not
performing therapeutic massage
uh
aside from all the health aspects that
we've started to talk about a little bit
um
the the reality is
that they
they're violating uh the codes in that
regard clearly as well we we've heard
stories uh we we talked with several
people
from the town of derry uh who came and
they said you know that
several of these establishments
in other parts of new hampshire as well
they they have uh
buckets for
toilets uh they
they are sleeping on the floor on
mattresses
they they they are living in the
establishment in a way uh they're living
their period is is clearly a violation
the the establishment is not there for
residential purposes so they're
violating the law there
they're violating the law with regard to
sanitation and and therefore health
requirements
they are not licensed to do therapeutic
massage and therefore
they
they're operating illegally and under
the the statute and your uh your
prerogatives as i understand it they
have every they they are
they're not permitted to legally operate
and you have the right to shut them down
is that not the case
so if an inspector goes into an
establishment
and determines that there are violations
if they rise to the level of an
emergency the board can emergently
suspend
their license we don't we're not law
enforcement so we can't shut down
businesses but we could emergently
suspend
the establishment license similarly to
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
could emergently suspend a shop license
which they have done
in some cases because everyone was
unlicensed and there were a lot of
sanitary conditions that raised great
issue
a great concern um so in that respect we
could
you cannot practice massage here you're
emergently suspended until
um that that suspension is lifted but we
are not law enforcement the board is not
law enforcement so we we can't shut
businesses down in the way that you may
have
intended
i think what um miss calif felidas said
earlier was that if the inspector
inspectors enter the establishment and
find that
in addition to hygienic issues there are
the potential for crime
if there's a potential crime then they
are allowed to notify the local
authorities so that
they the local authorities would be the
ones to address the crime not the lplc
right
that is correct as we're not law
enforcement we aren't going to ignore a
crime that we come across we would refer
it to local law enforcement
so that local led further legislation
would just need to clarify that so that
there isn't this gray area that was
misinterpreted by the
committee based on the testimony and the
bill itself
yes
president billy has a question
um in an hour we're dealing with
a similar thing
1444 relative to the registration of
medical spas
is there any particular reason why this
should look much different than that
except for the concerns of derry about
wanting to go in there all the time
can i make a comment on that the what
we're doing is we're addressing
the um the bills as written and whether
or not they are
can
is there something that we can do
in the fall to amend them or do they
need to be
basically do we need to start over this
would seem to have a lot of extraneous
material i was trying to compare it to
something similar
the bill that's similar
would be
a bill that that passed in the house a
while ago concerning cosmetology and
what we're trying to do is we're
comparing this bill
to previous legislation
that has um
similar
licensing requirements the medi-spa bill
is completely it's not it's new and it's
a completely different and it involves
different groups of people so this is a
bill that really just revolves around
oplc
and the massage
therapist the board the board of massage
therapists is there anybody here to
speak from
the board
no
because i believe they were notified
that's my understanding as well
yes representative rhodes has a question
so i i apologize i realized i walked in
lateness might have already been said so
i just wanted to um
one of the things that we heard
continuously in committee and it sounds
like
that was addressed with what you had
just mentioned
so i i think what i wanted to do my
biggest concern is um does there need to
be language that basically specifies
this isn't just a dairy issue right like
this is not just a local issue that
you know some of the concerns that we
have
happens all across the country not
necessarily in one town in the state of
new hampshire
correct and the um
the distinction that we want to make
with this bill that was not really made
adequately
during hearings was that this is a bill
that has to do with public safety and
hygiene and the reputation of
of employees and the reputation of of
owners of businesses
and um anything that's
extreme that's
outside of the sphere of hygiene or
public safety
would fall under the auspices of a law
enforcement and that this bill would
separate
where one
function begins and the other one starts
which wasn't very clear
in the bill which is why
we had um
we had this misunderstanding in the the
the bill was never meant to
address law enforcement but it wasn't
because it wasn't stated as such
it became
an issue
there any other questions
or comments
yes representative schmidt thank you
so
i don't care how we shut these people
down understand to the degree that they
are violating the law
in that they are
perp they are purporting to be a massage
establishment
as commonly understood
and yet they don't have a license
because they are not performing
therapeutic massage they are not trained
to do therapeutic massage they don't
have any of the credentials therefore
they cannot operate
legally
calling themselves and and they are also
violating the health and safety
standards that you are responsible for
so to the degree that you shut them down
um or
or
cause them to have to
go through the entire process of trying
to get licensed when they can't
so
it ain't when you say you're not law
enforcement well i beg to differ you're
not law enforcement in the traditional
sense but the law
uh that of the state of new hampshire
gives you the authority to intervene in
situations which which impact the
public's health and safety
so i don't care what you call it
the bottom line for me is that you have
the authority in my opinion to stop what
they are doing because it violates the
those those strictures of the law that
you are charged with enforcing
that is
law enforcement although not in the
traditional sense but you we don't we
don't have to we don't have to
have a policeman come in and we already
know that the police do not get involved
because they go in
[Music]
to the degree that they get involved at
all they go in they discover oh
this illegal sexual massage
uh is is occurring here then they arrest
the
the the one of the girls or several of
the girls they take them out the girls
get bailed out immediately they get sent
to another city new people come in and
the whole thing continues as it was
before just different faces
so law enforcement is not interested in
wasting their time
uh it's a cost of doing business for the
operators to bail somebody out send them
off
and they this is a waste of their time
but
so they're not going to get involved and
they don't have to be
because
you folks can stop them for the purposes
of protecting the public's health and
safety in my judgment so i think that if
we need to
amend a bill
to
change some particular aspect
and we don't call it law enforcement
because that would be typically
misunderstood to be the police
but they're not they don't they don't
want to get involved and they're not
going to get involved and they don't
have to be you can you can shut them
down for the purposes that we've already
been discussing
so this might help representative
schmidt
let's say
a business opens up in
a town
and it's called
pleasant massage
and
and they haven't they do not have
under this legislation a license
as a massage establishment
what would be the next step
yeah i am
trying to reference the um
because there are um
so if the establishment is on excuse me
is unlicensed
um
similar to barbarian cosmetology and
aesthetics there are a number of shops
that we
inspect and find don't have a shop
license
so that's unlicensed practice
so there if they have an individual
license the board could suspend that
we would also refer it to um
jay brown at the doj he handles all of
our unlicensed practice
cases and so he may pursue criminal
charges depending on the circumstances
okay so there's two ways that
so if they so if there's a lice if it's
a job that's open doesn't have a license
that can be pursued as
possible criminal activity
if there is a license
issued to a massage establishment and
upon inspection
there are violations
those violations could be
violations of
the oplc
rules
or criminal activity and if it's
criminal activity
the
oplc refers this to law enforcement is
that correct is that the way i'm
understanding it yes i believe that's
correct okay
representative rhodes
thank you
so if the
if a
if a person goes in to they inspect and
they see that this this place indeed is
not licensed let's just say that's the
case it's not licensed done
does the person that is there at that
exact time and sees that it is not
licensed because i heard what you said
about you know the department of justice
and investigations and so forth
i think earlier you were given an
example so
is there an example that you go in
they're not licensed it's
evidently clear
other things may be happening do you
have the ability right then and there
to
like a cease and desist
and then
until the investigation so you can get
the investigation launched and then it's
done you know like okay upon
investigations we found was really
happening like maybe it was you know
more into the weeds than you initially
thought but do you have the ability
right then and there
to stop if you have the ability to go in
the first place
uh we do not have the ability to say you
must cease and desist at this moment we
can tell them that you should not be
operating without
a license so that is unlawful for
unlicensed practice and that will be
referred
and what happens with the barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics is very often
they will continue to practice but we
have that date on which they were
it was made clear to them you do not
have a license you cannot practice
without one
um
and then when we refer it to doj they
they handle it from there and they have
a date certain that they've been
practicing without a license
do you have a recommendation if we're
going to
we're going to work on this legislation
and we bring it back
i think we all know the reasons why
we're so focused on it right now
so
let's just say representative grota and
i kind of team up and work on this
legislation i know she's worked on it
hard so i don't want to you know let's
just say we dive into this
is there verbiage that we're able to put
in here that would give you any kind of
that authority to say
stop
or does does that not exist anyway and
we just can't do that
i think
some boards have the authority to
issue cease and desist type letters but
due process
needs to be considered so that's after
notice and opportunity for hearing um
and what we're talking about here is
unlicensed and not necessarily
other
criminal activity that type of thing
that would again be referred to law
enforcement and they can probably take
action much sooner
um and more quickly um and again if the
person you know if it's unlicensed if
the establishment is unlicensed we can
refer that to doj and they can handle
that
if it's sanitary conditions and things
that are violated the board if it rises
to that level that they deem it it's an
emergency they can't emergently suspend
the license if they have one
until they
are able to rectify that situation
and furthermore if you are inspecting an
unlicensed facility and you find
criminal activity you can refer to law
enforcement
yes
so if i may um
one of the other aspects of the
the
establishment license
is that in order to be a
operating legally you have to have
licensed therapeutic
massage
[Music]
practitioners right
the girls in these places are not
therapeutic massage
practitioners right they are in most
cases captives
of these
operators okay
what we've heard is in many cases
maybe uniformly they're living
in the establishment
they have buckets for toileting purposes
representative schmidt we've already
discussed this i don't i think that your
need is being addressed by this
future legislation
i don't understand if you have a
question please ask the question and
don't repeat what you just said please
okay
uh my question is
since the practitioners also are
unlicensed
is it not the case that you can
that you can cite them for your
inspector can cite them for the fact of
having unlicensed practitioners
operating in their establishment
right so if we go in and the
establishment has unlicensed people
working there
their
establishment license could be
emergently suspended we did have a nail
salon where that was the case there were
i think five or six people working all
of which were unlicensed
um
and his shop license was emergently
suspended
um the idea there there was no um
evidence of criminal activity or
anything so that the goal there was
really
to
you know put the consequences on the
shop owner because he should have known
better and to get the people licensed so
that he can open back up we don't want
to
be a detriment to workforce um
so to the extent you know if somebody's
unlicensed
right that can be referred to doj and
they can decide based on the
circumstances to pursue that
the establishment license could be
emergently suspended
um
again that would effectively
they'd have to stop operating until they
were able to get that reinstated
and if we found any criminal activity we
would refer that to law enforcement and
they would pursue that
i accept your offer
if there are no further questions are we
i'd like to entertain a motion to
recommend or not recommend
is the language currently in the in the
appropriate form
representative schmidt all we're doing
today is recommending or not
recommending for further legislation any
amendments this bill will be done in
september but i realize that we are in
the end of the second term so there's
nothing we can do to
uh accept the motion that the chair has
just indicated or either yes or no on
future legislation and it's not even
binding
i can file the necessary legislation
completely independently of this process
it just adds a little bit of heft to it
if the committee's behind it so
but if we need license chain if we need
language changes i would ask that
you work with
me
anybody else who wants to get involved
to get the language into the shape we
need it in so that we can proceed
immediately other than that madam chair
a move that we recommend for future
legislation
see a second
second madam chair
okay
so um
so i'll take a roll call representative
bailey
you can vote since you're i know you're
here
yes
representative bailey votes yes
representative rhodes
representative schmidt
yes representative grotto votes yes so
is four to zero
to recommend for future legislation
i um
end the meeting and it is 10
27 thank you so much for being here and
we'll see you oh wait wait wait wait
hang on so sorry
we were all supposed to also address
uh senate bill
230 which had to do with um
which i don't have on my
on body are that's correct
so are we um
therefore going to adopt similar
legislation for body art is that what
we're going to recommend
um the committee could certainly decide
to do that it was pointed out that the
current language of
the body art
314a
does give the executive director
authority to draft rules regarding
inspections
um inspection of body piercing branding
and tattooing establishments that's 314
a um six
um so given that um we can attempt to
draft rules um the one concern that i
would have is if the establishments do
not have to be licensed or registered
that may impact our ability to inspect
but
the current language does allow us the
up the
option of drafting rules
is it possible that
some of these establishments
are actually people's homes
i
do not know the answer to that question
i couldn't say it's not within the realm
of possibility i don't know
so we would be adopting similar
legislation
to the
you're right i mean if there are rules
but this
this is this this is the same
situation as the massage establishments
right if there are no
hygienic
requirements
and we can't those those establishments
can't be
reviewed inspected because of current
legislation then we really don't have an
effective way of
enforcing the rules is that correct
uh yes i i
if there was a registration or a
licensing for establishments
um that would certainly help facilitate
inspection of those establishments
are there any comments from the
committee
yes
okay so we had the body art people
before us
several years ago already
those people are already licensed under
our new hampshire law
okay
they are all legitimate practitioners of
body art
science or whatever you call it
they came in
one of the problems with the whole
situation is
that health since the skin is being
broken and and
various different things are performed
under the skin or through the skin
it's clear that uh health and safety
aspects are paramount
okay and which is the reason that there
was discussion at the time
of
an
establishment license since that is the
place that you absolutely have to be
able to inspect and determine that they
are
doing things
in a safe way because otherwise you're
you're opening yourself up to a lot of
very
negative
uh skin and health ramifications okay
and these people are are aware of this
and and my understanding was that once
uh that
you know the licensing of the
practitioners went through that the
establishment licensing would also
uh follow so
what i'm hearing is that
that hasn't happened
correct the proposed
legislation would have allowed for
licensing of establishments
good okay well we certainly want to if
we if we need
a gap then i i will move that we
that we recommend this uh bill for
future legislation as well thank you
do you have any comments representative
bailey it's
it's
this is kind of a range of things where
tattoos at the top but
down at the level of piercings don't
they do this at malls
i mean i don't have pierced ears but
it's like
um yes so there are
um you know you can
ear piercings there's places you can get
in the mall this includes um body
piercing
which could be
your belly button your tongue
um other more sensitive areas
yeah
so in the current statute body piercing
means the creation of an opening in
human tissue except piercing of the
earlobe
thank you
no no you know
the the um
ear piercing is all over the place uh
and it's a common practice
uh even there
some health
uh strictures are
clearly in order uh and uh but uh the
types of things we're talking about in
body art is a wholly
a different thing
so
anyway so i didn't hear a second
well it's again it's a world i don't
move in but don't even teenage girls do
this to each other
um when you say this could you clarify
i've heard that
it's obviously not the world i'm
but this bill accepts that yeah
so i think
that's
that's the difference so it doesn't
matter well we've sometimes had things
with like well this
individuals do things that are right and
are not licensed
right okay
um
so i will second
representative schmidt's
um
motion
and um
are we ready to vote
representative bailey
yes
representative schmidt aye
representative photo grotto votes yes
uh so it's three to zero for
recommendation for future legislation
thank you and now i'm really closing
this part of the hearing at 10 35 thank
you
you gotta hear distance i'm adam
director
what capacity are they being employed
and how will we see them
uh in the next year presuming that any
of us got get reelected
um i think i'll let them all introduce
themselves if that's all right
hi my name is lauren warner and i am the
new board general counsel employed by
oplc so you may see me
this next legislative session
um being here representing the boards
specifically
i
they've been ordered i haven't received
them yet so i will once i ever have them
oh would you like
perhaps you can have
the board
uh the oplc
send us the names of and contact
information
for yourself and and your two colleagues
yeah and i can certainly do this when i
get back to the office and send it on to
we can live without your card for the
moment
my name is l thompson i'm one of the
legal interns with the enforcement
division so i'm actually only with oplc
for the remainder of the summer season
for 2022.
my name's meredith byerly i am also an
enforcement legal intern so i am also
only here for the summer
thank you for attending it's wonderful
to see you here
utilize your time strike while the iron
is hot
so our next hearing is subcommittee
hearing is at 11 so we can all
take a stretch
committee work session on house bill
which is the registration of medical
spas
um
originally this bill
um was presented to the committee and
there was significant
pushback from a group of physicians
from a group that was called a10
and upon
review
this was this is a lobbying organization
that did not identify themselves as such
and at the time
with my
inquiry into the secretary of state's
office they had not been registered as a
lobbying organization
so since then
they are now telling me they are a
lobbying organization but they are not
here
and therefore we should just proceed
without them unless they show up
their
[Music]
excuse me their
objection to the bill was that
they're doctors they know what they're
doing and they don't need to be
overseen by
another organization
um
and upon
discussions with
medical spa owners
after the hearing
it was learned that
doctors will
sell their name to these organizations
as medical directors
yet they have no responsibility
and therefore
they can sell their names to as many
organizations as they want
and there is no requirement to them it
says that you have to have access
for a medical director but there's no
that is not really specified accesses
could be a name on a web page
it's not
access
for
an issue that could come up during a
procedure
so based on that information the sub the
committee recommended that we review
this legislation
in a work
in the subcommittee work session and um
i'll leave it at that is there any
comment from
oplc on this because this is something
that we did discuss
um i
just briefly um
we did discuss this and
i think that you you did address some of
the concerns that you know doctors are
in some instances selling their name so
it looks like they have a medical
director but in practice they really
don't have any anyone who
has the medical expertise
to perform the the treatments and
procedures or oversee them or delegate
them appropriately
which puts the public at risk um
so that's that's a big part part of it
um
this the potential the proposed
legislation
does ensure that
these procedures which are they are
cosmetic in nature but they are
absolutely medical in nature
and i think that there is sometimes
a feeling that well it's just cosmetic
but it is medical it does require proper
qualifications in order to diagnose and
come up with a treatment plan and then
to supervise and delegate appropriately
it does require
proper
education and training
um both for the physician or the aprn or
the the naturopath who oversees the
the med spa but also for staff and so
there has to be somebody properly
qualified to ensure that that's
occurring
this
came up for me in that
hair salons in portsmouth
and it's very lucrative right it's very
expensive
and um
so hair salons are starting to
extend into this area
and when i've asked them well who is
actually doing the treatment and who's
you know medically supervising it's a
very wishy-washy
kind of answer
and that wishy-washiness
is to me a concern
i think this is the kind of legislation
that needs to be
addressed and specified
it could be
as simple as okay if there's a medical
director they have to be available by
phone or by in person within a certain
amount of time if there's an issue
um
it could be as simple as that or it
could be
a little bit more
complicated it could be a little bit
more intense so
um
do you have any recommendations
on how we could address this in future
legislation
um so the the proposed legislation i
think
um
would address it um there may be
certainly you know room for improvement
in what was proposed
for example
um the
medical director has to be readily
available it may be better to specify
what that is um
i would point out that
and i believe
everybody on the committee is aware that
the boards of medicine nursing
um
pharmacy and barbarian cosmetology and
aesthetics all supported this
legislation they saw the need for it
not only to protect the the public but
also the licensees because for somebody
who is an esthetician who may be
working for a med spa who is told to do
something that they it might be outside
their scope of practice it would clarify
that for them and give them something to
point to and say i can't do that without
the proper delegation
um so i think the language as as
proposed
did meet a lot of the um
it would mean you know it would address
a lot of the concerns i certainly agree
that there may be room for improvement
though
one of the
concerns brought forth by a-10
was that some of these
practices
do perform
esthetician procedures like facials and
and that they
say
that there is a wall between that part
of the business
and the medical part
and that
and how would we
ensure that i mean it's that i i get i
you know saying it doesn't make it so
not necessarily so how do we
distinguish
between for those practices exactly that
you talked about right the place where
it's if it's a spa
yet they're going to they're going to
conduct medical procedures so how would
we distinguish that
um through inspection we would be able
to determine if
you know if if you go into a room that
is supposed to just be an esthetician's
shop for example um where that's the
only thing supposed to be practiced is
within the scope of practice of an
esthetician and you find botox
um
you know the inspector finds botox that
would be an indication that that person
is very likely practicing outside their
scope of practice and we could
investigate further
um and i would like to point out the the
language does um
you know indicate that and i'm looking
at
this would be 313 b3 exemptions nothing
in this chapter shall be construed so as
to prohibit any individual license by
any regulatory board from performing
functions or duties within the scope of
such individuals license so if there is
an esthetician on staff who has a room
that is solely doing esthetician
um
things that are within an esthetician
scope of practice that would be
perfectly legal
so then
since you have the nursing board the
medical board and the
pharmaceutical board all in support
how would
that
would your who would who would be
conducting the inspections on these
the inspectors would have all three
would have three
jurisdictions is that right
so for the inspectors
um
the the bill as as proposed would
allow the executive director to adopt
rules relative to the qualifications of
inspectors
so that would need to be determined
we would likely need
somebody from the different
areas of expertise the different boards
to weigh in on what would be needed and
going into a medical spa because right
now we have pharmacy inspectors can go
in and do solely
pharmaceuticals
if there is an esthetician who has a
shop within a medical spa our barber and
cosmetology and aesthetics inspectors
can go in but they are very limited they
have to it's only that shop they can't
go into other areas and look so it would
be somebody who would be qualified to
um
look at various types of licensees
so botox is a control substance is that
correct
i don't know the answer to that so i'm
asking
i'm not certain if it's a controlled
substance but you absolutely need a
prescription
it's a prescription you can't just buy
it over the counter
so one of the concerns that had been
brought up by the board of pharmacology
was that
they were noticing that
botox
vials were being used for more than one
person
which is a clear violation of
the administration of a
pharmaceutical
through injection
so
i'm just trying to figure out if there
is
if an institution if for example
the um inspector were to find botox
there
why is it that the pharmaceut
pharmacology board would know that they
would have had access to it
could you clarify the question
right so if there's a pers oh i see it
would be a prescription they'd have to
have a prescription to have the botox
and who would have issued that
subscription for somebody who isn't
licensed or
how does that work
um you would need to have the the proper
authorization to order botox um
my understanding is there are people who
have gotten their hands on botox who are
not authorized i do not know how that
occurred
but that is
certainly not legal
so perhaps a point in the legislation
would be that
the access to botox has to be
i mean we should clarify that
so that if it's not if if prescription
products are being used
with a
um
i'm not gonna use the word illegal but
an unlawful
um
process
then that's also a violation i would
think
is that right
um that would that's right i i think it
could be clarified here um i think the
medical practice act and
the pharmacy um the statutes relating to
pharmacy require that only certain
qualified individuals with certain
authorizations are able to
um
you know order prescription type
medications like botox
so it could be clarified here but i
think those statutes would require that
and then we'd also go for the i mean i
would imagine the fillers have to be
middle medical grade fillers i mean they
just can't be
i don't know anything really i don't
know i know very little about this but i
would imagine that that is also
something that's done by prescription
that's my understanding okay so we need
to clarify that i think too
does that commit you any questions
representative bailey
no
well
but would you put the name of botox
right in there or is it just to kind of
generally
you know there's all kinds of crazy
things they do they have fish that
nibble on people and you know
uh you know
you can't gonna list all the crazy
things they do right it's just if it
reaches the threshold of medical rather
than specifying botox or
right i i believe the barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics um
forbids the use of animals and
that type of thing so there should no
longer be fish left in pedicures you had
heard of this i'm aware of i'm aware it
has been a thing in the past
right so um
there may be a more general way of
phrasing it pharmaceutical or
something like that or an inject
anything injected
i don't have to specify fish
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so i i want to come back to the issue of
medical directors
um
maybe you can even put that in quotation
marks
because if they are just
as has been
stated previously
they're just selling their name
to some entity
and they they're not really engaged then
it's kind of like
i don't know
donald trump putting his name on a
building that that he has no involvement
with except his name he sold the name
rights
um
but that doesn't say anything about
but it it's misleading to the public in
my opinion
to in in this kind of an instance what
he
what he's doing that example i gave
that's a different situation because
um
and he's not the architect he's not the
investor he's only selling the naming
rights it's a total different thing it's
kind of a branding situation
as opposed to
this person saying they are the medical
director but they ain't
except potentially legally i think we
have to of course
we would have to define what
available
remember you said earlier that they said
that and then you have to define what
medically available means with regard to
one of these people i'm very concerned
that that this is way too much of a wild
west
situation in new hampshire currently
and to the degree that you've got people
i mean
i gave the executive director an example
that we had in committee
a number of years ago before
not before any of you were born it
wasn't that long ago but
before some of you were around in the
state legislature or in oplc and so
forth and there was an example of this
couple that came into a
mall
and there was somebody standing there
wearing a white coat and they were
offering free teeth whitening
so i said
you know typical
they look at each other they go like
kind of what could go wrong
and all of us who have been in the
legislature for a while well let me how
much time we got to tell you what could
go wrong
because
we had pictures
that the husband brought
of his wife's inflamed lips and gums
uh from whatever substance they used
either too much of or the wrong stuff
and so forth and when you're
messing with somebody's face
that is something that people are
extremely sensitive about men and women
um
and and so forth so you just can't have
that kind of a thing and these people
assume the white coat meant something
medical
instead it meant some something more
like fraud
or incompetence so god knows what so
these spas i think are way way way too
wild west
here in new hampshire
so i think we
especially the medical directors are
going to have to have
way more engagement
with the entity
that they that they are
stating they are the medical director of
otherwise
they can't
be um
and i've heard some kind of reference
that some of these spas
are perhaps
renting their services
for like
bridal showers or wedding parties or so
forth and so on
now you're having procedures performed
at
the event
and if any kind of a mistake is made
you know
and and parties perhaps there might be
alcohol consumed
by some of the people at some of these
parties and so forth this is just an
invitation in my judgment to abuse and
and reckless endangerment of the public
so i'd like to see much more
um
specification about medical
directors
required engagement with the entity that
they are directing
so that would be my feeling thank you
may i respond briefly
um so i i agree with you um the proposed
legislation did
define what a medical director was who
that person could be in terms of
qualifications and what the requirements
would be for that type of person
um so that's that's in there and i i do
agree there's probably a lot of medical
spas who might be doing things right um
and we've talked to some of some
attorneys who represent
such spas and they basically say this
codifies everything they're doing right
so for those those institutions i don't
think this would have that big an impact
but there are those that a doctor sells
their name to it gives the appearance of
a medical director when in fact there
may really be no medical oversight
is there anything in existing statute
that parallels this or something that
you have to say that he's a he
participates or that he has oversight or
is there some kind of way to address
that
um
i'm not i looked at some other i tried
to try to find some other legislation
that might be similar especially in
other new england states
and didn't find anything sort of on
point
for example connecticut
does have a statute but it's much more
restrictive because it requires
a physician physician assistant or an
aprn not only diagnosed but actually do
all the treatments
um
so it was i was unable to in the
research i i conducted find something on
point for what were precisely what we're
looking to do here um so that language
should have to be crafted
one
thought might be
two
and maybe this is too complicated but to
change the
nomenclature from medical spa
to medical cosmetics
i'm just wondering whether or not the
word spa
is causing the because people think of
you know the place that you can go and
have
a sauna and a massage and i mean that's
that's a spa right but this is medical
cosmetology and i'm wondering whether or
not we should think about
defining it
out of the spa realm so that people
understand it better
is that that makes sense
i think that does make sense i think the
use of the word spa sometimes does
create confusion
so that would be something that we might
consider
because i think that makes it more when
you say you know medical cosmetology
that brings i mean that to me in my head
brings
some alarm bells right because you're
thinking okay
this is not
a facial or
a my appeal or whatever right
correct okay
i just think i want to pick up on that
recent colloquy with regard to the word
spa because
it's a word that everybody knows
and everybody has a different definition
of
um and to the degree that you're you're
making money off of the term
uh we're going to have to have
much more definition i think of what
what spa means
especially in regard to this particular
category that we're talking about here
so
and i have you rece you've mentioned
connecticut have you researched some
other states massachusetts
um you know
is even closer to us of course and much
more interaction with connect than with
new hampshire than connecticut has
right um i did
do
some research on the new england states
i provided a letter it was dated january
24th to house edna regarding regarding
that but and i have a copy here if you
you'd like it
massachusetts requires a medical spas be
licensed with the department of public
health in that state in that state they
oversee the medical boards
so that's why that entity is um where
the license where the medical spas have
to be licensed
they do require licensure unless it
falls into the exception for entities
which are wholly owned and controlled by
one or more of its medical practitioners
and does not use certain terms in its
name such as clinic or institute so
if it's not wholly owned by a medical
professional they have to be licensed in
massachusetts
so it appears that the
legislation that we're looking at
is
strictly aimed at
protecting the public and this is a good
first step
to do that
yes um and if i may point out one other
difference with massachusetts that was
licensure what we were proposing was a
registration
we still are proposing that
right okay
so what would the registration
as opposed to a licensure
how would that differ as far as
the public and the owner of the facility
or are we saying if they're registering
they that they are
agreeing okay
yes miss courtney
so generally under um administrative
laws registration and licensure are
treated the same for legal purposes
except that there is a distinction which
i think is important for our purposes
with respect to this legislation
registration there's generally no
discretion as to whether to place you on
the registry the qualifications are not
substantial it's uh you've paid the fee
and you get on the list
um versus what we see and that's very
similar to the med tech registry
somebody says that they are around
controlled substances they pay the fee
they get on the list
as opposed to a license to practice
nursing uh we need your transcripts we
need your references we need your
criminal history check and all of all of
those requirements so
the reason why we
we sought to establish the registry
the the bill is proposed really just
clarified the existing state of the law
in new hampshire which is that if you're
performing a medical procedure
um
and there needs to be a diagnosis not
that it's medically indicated but that
there are no contraindications and the
only people who can make that diagnosis
are
an mddo or pa under the supervision of
an mddo or an aprn and then they could
certainly delegate those tasks and what
we have and that's the existing state of
the law
but it's unclear
and
because it's not explicitly stated
anywhere and there is a lot of
overlap and confusion between medical
procedures and cosmetic procedures
um and we
this
bill came about rather organically
because we were receiving complaints
um
about people who had been injured
from
individuals who were not qualified a
prime example being one complaint was
that a licensed nursing assistant had
whipped up some
uh
facial cream or was it a chemical peel
and was was it
advising people via telehealth how to
administer the chemical peel
completely outside the scope of what
they're allowed to do but because it's
cosmetic
they felt that it was appropriate we had
another individual who was injured with
laser therapy
and this wasn't laser that was just
going just below the surface it goes
fairly deep and they're permanently
scarred because
the person didn't assess they were not
qualified to assess whether laser was
appropriate on that individual
nor did they have supervision
from a qualified person so they were
permanently
disfigured so you know i think the bill
would propose the existing or would
clarify the existing state of the law
with respect to scope of practice but
then it also allows us to ensure
compliance through the registration and
the inspections
it's you know it's
from my perspective i don't think it's
that intrusive because individuals who
practice in this field generally are
subject to inspections
and um there are no additional
requirements that one has to
meet in order to have a medical uh
whatever we would like to call it but
yeah i agree with you your comments
regarding the spouse
thank you
are there any further questions
go ahead
because registration i mean we have you
know your highest level is licensing
where it's something where you have to
have qualifications
uh you're subject to
revocation suspension
uh and so forth uh certification is a
lower level uh it says you know how to
do something
um
and and uh of course the the terms have
have uh
like
the term rn
is registered nurse and it's a
traditional
term right
but in point of fact right rns are all
licensed
and
and so and you have certified public
accountants i think they're also
licensed even though they're called cpa
because it's a traditional
title
so there's a lot of i shouldn't say a
lot but it certainly is a considerable
amount of overlap so it it's not
strictly
delineated from one to the other but
registration is
pretty weak t in my view
for some for an entity that is going to
be messing with people's face
if i may um the registration would just
give us authority to inspect and if
there were
findings
then we would refer those out to the
different regulatory boards
what we've observed is that
you know as jessica explained
cosmetology pharmacy um
and at the other inspect inspections
they they all operate in their own
little silo there's no one
person that can look at everything and
there is
overlap between
these different professions so we wanted
the ability to go in and look at
everything and then refer out to the
appropriate regulatory body if there was
an issue
so miss courtney in relationship to the
previous bill um
you would be writing the rules for that
inspector is that correct yes okay
legislation we need a motion to
recommend for future legislation
whatever you think the recommendation
should be
the motion should be i'm happy to move
that because i absolutely don't want to
see this be
continue to be the wild west that it is
becoming the wilder west
if we don't have any
appropriate legislation or statutory
authority
so
move that do you want to continue
representative bailey seconds
i will call the role representative
schmidt
representative bailey
representative grotto votes yes those
three to zero to recommend for future
legislation
and are there any other
topics or questions or comments if not i
close the hear the subcommittee work
session
i want to thank the um you all and i
want to thank the committee members for
putting a lot of thought
and making these work sessions
substantive so thank you so much
clock
hey sally
we'll just wait for a few minutes for uh
representative fellows to to get back
and see if representative rhodes shows
up
yeah
it's um
that's what i heard it's myself roads
and fellows but as long as we have two
people we can
do things
okay i'm going to call this subcommittee
work session on house bill 1312 to order
um and
you'd like to call mr sherman if you
could come up we were talking earlier
and he can give you his views on this
and then we can
move on from there
thank you for inviting me here today
i think uh we have two issues with hp
1312 as it stood
one is that it directly conflicts with
155a which is the enabling rsa for the
building code and then it's the building
code review board
which prohibits
state agencies from amending the
building code
understanding that with des there was
some
uh
i'll call confusion in a gentlemanly way
as to where the building code applied
and did not apply we can sort that out
we feel we're on pretty firm ground
having talked to people who have been
around a lot longer than i have
so
just that on the face of it would say
1312 hopefully will
die a quick death
i believe we have legislation in place
155 a 2x
which permits state agencies to come to
the building code review board amend the
building code
as as they would desire and get reviewed
and then it becomes a state amendment
applicable to everyone
we in no way shape or form are trying to
cut anybody out of looking at grease
traps half the towns in the state don't
have a building inspector so obviously
you know there's got to be a working
together there so i think that uh in
terms of the specific rules
uh
what we really need is some time and it
may be extensive time as i indicated in
my email the other day a very quick
cursory look at rules among different
agencies and departments
this is an issue that that's endemic
dhhs doe almost everybody seems to have
a rule at some point
that effectively amends the building
code without calling it amendment to the
building code
so that would seem to conflict with the
current rsa as it stands
as i indicated mr leckus earlier i
believe we've got some editorial work to
do on our rsa in the next year or two
just to clarify some terminology but the
intent seems to be very clear and in
fact has been enforced over the years
notably with a
discussion with some elevator folks at
one point
so what i'm here today
in hope of is some kind of an interim
way
to allow us some time to work in a in a
coordinated manner with the various
agencies
uh whether it be through gel car or
otherwise
uh to to figure out where all of these
things are popping up in the in the
various rsas and the rules
and then get them resolved through
amendments to the building code
uh and to not have uh an rsa that sort
of sits over here that says well des can
write rules on their own that amend the
building code that now we've got a
direct conflict between two two sections
right and i would think that i mean you
said that you could incorporate those
rules in the building code but i would
think you know as part of the review
board you look at and see is that really
appropriate and necessary and some of
them it may be
appropriate for them to go ahead with
most things in life there are 17 members
on the building code review board
somebody's going to have an opinion
about something
okay yeah
um i think reflecting also on a comment
that was made back at the hearing
uh that does start with a model code and
then amends that model code where
there's a need to amend it uh
rather than leaving the model code in
conflict with local state rules
um
if you'll be available for questions
absolutely after this what i'd like to
do is get a representative from
department of environmental services
gonna to
give their take on this
which i sent to
um
all right
all right so good afternoon uh for the
record
my name is philip trobridge i'm the
manager of the land resource programs at
des which includes the subsurface
systems bureau which is where the
regulations regarding grease traps
reside
and what i just handed to you was some
information that i provided to
ols um i think probably i didn't know if
it was passed on to you all but you know
from
uh he had asked for some
clarifications of our regulations
regarding grease traps and
uh and under what circumstances we could
waive those regulations
um
because i think it's one thing if you
look at page two
um
you know we we have the ability to
to make waivers whenever uh it's
justified
and
we actually
do you know waive the requirement for
things like grease traps
um under circumstances that are pretty
well defined when there is you know a
food establishment where there's not
going to be very much grease
you know whether there's seeding or not
uh there's high water high temperature
dishwashers which tends to mobilize
grease and those kinds of things
so i just bring this up to you know in
the i guess in the context of the
uh
that the desire for house bill 1312
um
seeks some flexibility
uh in the sizing and the requirements
for grease traps
um
i wanted you all to be aware that we we
have that flexibility now in our current
rules
uh and we exercise it currently so i
have kind of a more basic question and
that is um
as was mentioned in
rsa155a2 it says no state agency
authority board or commission shall very
modify or waive the requirements the
state building code or the state fire
code
um
unless approved by the state building
code review board and so the question is
um
you know
was this rule uh passed by the state
the building code review board and was
it approved by them
because it does impinge i would argue on
aspects of the building code
uh well the grease traps that we require
under our regulations are outside the
building so they are you know different
from the jurisdiction of the building
code which would be inside the building
yeah so there are these you know smaller
interior grease traps
um and those those relate to plumbing
codes and things like that
the the build the grease traps for
under the subsurface system rules are
external they're they're basically part
of the septic system okay there seems to
be some dispute on that point actually
if mr sherman could come back you seem
to indicate some disagreement
yeah you can both sit at the table
actually or sit there at that table
probably is best given that i assume
this is being uh recorded given my
number of friends with cove it will keep
a little bit of distance
whatever you're comfortable with
so i understand fully and we have not
had a chance to coordinate this and have
a discussion about it but uh the the
building code in this case we're talking
about the plumbing code
is absolutely clear and i've reviewed
this with others that our jurisdiction
goes to either the public sewer or the
septic tank they call it a building
sewer whatever goes across the front
yard is still within
the building codes baileywick so the
issue of insider outside matters on
other things but it doesn't really
matter to which code applies
we need to have a discussion about that
we need to work together and zip zip
these two things together somehow
sure okay i mean that's excellent point
and it's come up in other contexts too
you know where the the line is for
uh septic system jurisdiction you know
we've typically operated of
assuming five feet from the
building foundation
but you know i think if there's any
ambiguity we should clear that up one
one of the reasons that there's
continual confusion is that the plumbing
licensing does not does not align with
the plumbing code
so the plumbing licensing stops some
distance outside the building foundation
which was set basically due to the
length of a piece of pipe
and that continually comes up as a point
of confusion
but the code itself goes all the way to
the sewer of the septic tank
um thank you i'm
just a little confused about this i
looked at the
the international plumbing code which is
the basic part of the state's code and
then we amend
make amendments to it
and
what i found there
um
matched what i found when i just googled
grease traps
and i
and
the code
has to do with
how what kind and how much of a grease
trap with the capacity of the grease
trap
is a function of
the flow
of water into
flow going uh from whatever sink or
a piece of equipment you're dealing with
and
there certainly are grease traps that
can reside inside the kitchen not even
just the building but the kitchen
and that
if somebody were
following the code
that
in the particular case we heard about
i'm thinking that
the
a
licensed designer of septic
whatever
um
could
easily say that
for a
small restaurant
which is certainly
the case that we heard about certainly
was
that
an outside grease trap probably wasn't
even necessary so this is i i'm not a
plumber so that's what i found
so
can you respond to that and tell me did
i get it wrong or am i missing something
or is something else out of line
no i can't
uh my technical expertise has nothing to
do with grease traps i'm a fire
protection engineer
i'm the chair of the building code
review board and on that board we have
others whose expertise is plumbing and
related related issues so that's why i'm
saying i think we need the time to have
a conversation and see how we can zip
these things together do the appropriate
amendments to the state code where there
is overlap
and then have people able to look at one
document
and uh
you know in an ideal world the rules on
grease traps would say comply with the
state building code as they do in other
other rules for other purposes
okay i think
yeah so i guess i could respond a little
bit to your question um yeah and i i
think you're you know
read is essentially correct it's but
it's a little there's other elements to
it in terms of you know the uh
the type of food that's being cooked and
the type of appliances that are in the
facility
and the number of customers and whether
there's uh you know restroom facilities
or it's just a takeout facility so
the uh there's kind of a calculation you
can make essentially of the amount of
grease that might be generated
and then therefore
the amount of storage or you know the
size of the grease trap that's needed
and that's also related to the frequency
in which you'd want to have that you
know disposed of
so it it's you know these all can be
sized
you know scaled in whatever way
it works but they
it has to be done as a you know in an
integrated fashion where someone is
thinking carefully about well if i want
to have a small grease strap i really
need to have this pump out truck come
every
week or every you know a couple of days
and do i want is that worth the payment
for the cost to do that
so
you know it can be you know the grease
can be managed with any different sizes
but it comes down to kind of like what's
the most efficient way of doing it
so i agree that there's i guess um
with the sentiment that we should spend
a little time thinking about it and how
we could structure this in a way
that is easier for people to understand
um and right now we you know we use some
discretion when we encounter a facility
that doesn't have a fry later it doesn't
have a high temperature dishwasher and
those kind of things and we can say yeah
we can waive the requirement
for the for the external grease trap
but you know perhaps there's a way that
that can be more clearly articulated in
rule or in the plumbing code
follow-up
thank you
so
my thought is the way that somebody
would move forward with
a new small restaurant or some kind of
expansion of an existing one
is that they would
be contacting somebody who has a license
to do
design
related to grease traps and i don't know
who that is i don't know if that's a
regular plumber or somebody with a
special license
and that they would
present they would develop the design
and
present it to the state and
i'm thinking
i'm sick i don't know if people can hear
because i'm talking sideways um
that they would
accept that design i don't even really
understand
why the state would be doing anything
other than just reviewing it
and that's essentially what we do you
know we you know people come to us for
you know a septic system approval
and then part of that design for the
sepsis and would include a grease trap
if it's a food establishment
and unless you know they can make the
case that this is you know a low grease
generating facility and therefore we're
going to seek a waiver
for that grease trap
you know and so we review that plan and
then we approve that plan and then
that's constructed according to the
approved plan
so that's the process we use now
okay yeah hang on i'll get to
um
i'm gonna have representative aaron talk
about this particular case but as i
understand it um
i'm not an expert on grease traps or
plumbing
but it seemed pretty clear that what was
being demanded was over the top and you
can say you have discretion and that's
great if it's exercised reasonably
and again it appears to me i'm not an
expert it appears to me that was not the
case this time and that's what raised
this issue
and that
if nothing else the decision was drug
out long enough that
you know the
people are concerned actually ended up
having to put the grease trap in
to operate their business
and so you know that is a serious
concern
also i think it's pretty clear and maybe
we can clarify 155a2
that
you know des cannot be putting in rules
that impinge on the area covered by
the state building code and maybe
there's a misunderstanding about that
about where that boundary was in
different cases and and you know it's
great if there's some communication
going on to clarify that that would be
good
but representative aaron
thank you
representative likus um
so yeah what you described mr trewbridge
in in terms of how
things are supposed to work was not what
happened and
and i would say that this is not the
only
constituent of mine that this has
occurred with because there have been
other issues other times when other
businesses have
have come across the same kind of
problem but for my constituent
balthazars in goshen
new hampshire
they were featured on chronicles and
then the very next day
an inspector came down to their place
and closed them down because they said
they did not have the proper size grease
trap
now they had already gotten a license
they were already licensed to do the
work they were doing
and all of a sudden this issue comes up
that that they need this thousand gallon
grease trap
i don't believe that there was any kind
of um
waiver
explained to them or any kind of
situation where they would have had
any way in which to modify what d s was
telling them they needed in order to
keep their license
they were just told you have to put in a
thousand gallon grease trap otherwise
you lose your license and we have to
shut you down
so
what are they supposed to do
and they went ahead and they spent
thousands of dollars to have this system
installed which is
way more than what they would ever need
for the type of work uh type of food
that they produce
the shed that they that they
scoop their food out of
is is just about the same size as the
grease trap that they installed so i
mean how could you even think that or
how could even how could des even think
that
a thousand gallon grease trap well one
size fits all situation
would be appropriate in this way i
that's all i'm going to say about that
would like to respond yeah it just
briefly
i i believe in this particular case
there was a change in their menu and so
their original design that they were
approved for was
i think just ice cream and then
you know they expanded to
um some you know other types of foods
and and
so which triggered the
the you know whereas before the the
grease trap is not needed for just
scooping ice cream um
and
then if you're going to fried foods then
that's kind of where the threshold for
us you know we've
uh to say well this is now you're now
into a situation where you need that and
we do have you know the rules just say
it's a thousand gallons so it means that
we didn't have a an option of sort of
scaling it and saying okay
your facility is just
only doing
you know french fries and therefore you
can have a 500 gallon tank you know it's
you're either in or you're out
and i think that's what happened in this
case um so i think that that was one of
the reasons why
there was the change
as far as i understand
the amount of grease that they would
have produced with the enhanced
menu
was not even an issue because all their
fry laters were self-contained they
weren't dumping any of that down the
sink
and they had
all the food that they serve is on
disposable plates so it's not like
they're cleaning any of that in a
dishwasher so
even any minimal amount
of grease that they would be producing
putting on utensils that they use in
their establishment
would no way
need a thousand gallon grease trap
an under the sink grease trap would be
appropriate for this kind of
establishment and that's what other
plumbers uh
and experts in the field had had advised
them as well
but again you have no way in which to uh
say in this case you can have
a 500 gallon grease trap or a 200 gallon
grease or whatever
so and i think and and i had written to
um
to the commissioner
asking him for
a change in the rules and basically
was told
we'll look at it so
i hope you look at it right and the uh
there was a that information i was
passed passing out earlier just saying
you know the areas where we could
consider
us either a smaller system or no system
is is kind of our as i've been pressing
staff to say well under you know what
are our thresholds for this you know and
that are clear for us to decide because
you know we
you know we're not
um you know equipped to go out and
really
dig into exactly how many customers does
somebody have and you know of what type
of meal do they make
it's more you know do they have a fry
later you know do they have a high
temperature dishwasher you know do they
have seating uh do they use paper
service or china service so those were
the kind of black and white thresholds
we're
using to say we could you we could put
something like this in rule because it's
black and white and it's easy for us to
evaluate on a plan
and and that would allow us to be
communicate to people clearly like in
those circumstances we can waive this
role
or we could have a lower tier
authorization for under the under the
sink restrap
but you know that's the the effort
spawned by your letter was to come up
with some black and white thresholds
that we could use either for waivers or
for a change in the rule so my my
understanding and people can correct me
if it's wrong is that
um it's actually inappropriate for des
to have created rules in this area at
all
unless they had first gone and gotten it
reviewed by the building code review
board i don't know
um
what the national plumbing code part as
amended by new hampshire that's uh
in the
state building code i don't know
what it says in this specific area it
may have
more
rules that will come accommodate
different situations but i think this
rule is actually invalid under statute
completely
because it didn't follow the process
required in statute and i don't know
you said you're not an expert on grace
traps do you happen to know if
there is something more flexible that's
part of the npc
oh i'll catch you in a moment
what is very clear as as we get into
this whole discussion is that in any of
the rules there may be a piece of it
that overlaps with the plumbing code
while much of the rest of it doesn't
yeah
there's also a
very
common regulatory problem where
designing something based on what
somebody says they're going to do when
they operate the building is always like
catching butterflies
right i promise we're never going to
sell cheeseburgers only hamburgers well
who enforces that
and even when we talk about the issue of
waivers between the rule
the des rules and the building code
in the jurisdictions that don't have a
building inspector who does the waiver
if it's in the building code so there's
a lot of these issues that really need
thoughtful consideration and zipping
together before we jump
uh my opinion okay one thing is if
you're not actually speaking please turn
the mics off because only so many can be
on
and there's a gentleman here i think
would like to speak
and if you can introduce yourself
yeah good afternoon for the record i'm
rainey pelletier i'm the
director of the water division at des of
which uh one of the programs that's
under my purview if you will is on-site
wastewater
so
what i will try and do is add some
clarity to i think what is
uh
a lot of confusion by
a lot of us
the
first of all the plumbing code has
nothing to do with what a structure has
the ability to discharge the state's
groundwaters of the state
plumbing code or building codes designed
if you're going to install this that or
the other thing that there's an
appropriate approach in the technologies
and the method that you use
when we did rules and i've been at des
forever
and i was in the subsurface program back
in 73
in 67 is when the subsurface rules came
in
back in the days when
we dealt with the plumbing board
because we license pump installers we
license waste water and drinking water
operators and so forth and so on
so
the confusion here is that the the
building code has no idea or no control
over what is coming out of a structure
from a wastewater point of view that is
certainly under des purview
so when we go in and we say you require
a grease trap or we approve a septic
system
then it's based on what the quantity
and the quality of the waste water that
will come out of that structure and go
into the ground which is on the onsite
wastewater septic system
when this particular situation came in
there was an approved septic system
which in fact no way alluded to the fact
there was going to be fryer laters
grease traps any other issues
that took place it's like
saying that it is not uncommon people
come in we approve a septic system for
three bedrooms three years down the road
we get a phone call from the building
inspecting and saying hey there's
another bedroom
so we can ultimately number one i don't
have the staff to go out and see what
people are doing most of the time unless
we get a complaint
but
i'm trying to be very clear that the
building code
and what is state approved for
discharging wastewater to the ground a
two different purviews
very different
so the plumbing cord does not dictate
what kind of waste water should be
approved to come out of a structure
so
i would disagree that in fact our rules
went in place
neglecting the statute of the building
code 155.
anybody have any questions
representative fellows
so let me see if i can
i'm putting the pieces together right
here i'm trying
so
you're saying that your purview
is to be able to say
no grease should be flowing
out into the ground or
a
brook or whatever okay
but
what gives you the authority
to determine how
how that is managed because there are
grease traps that can be inside the
building and there are grease traps that
can be outside the building and there
are plumbing codes
that relate to grease traps that say
what size of trap you need
based on flow
good question and first of all whatever
gets discharged to the ground in the
surface waters of hopefully nothing to
the surface waters but the wastewater
system is under the purview of des
that is the regulatory authority we have
under 485
which in fact does control what kind of
waste is discharged
in the building code or the plumber's
code they in fact would certainly have
jurisdiction on
a grease trap
but as far as the determination of what
the volume the quality of the waste
water is
and how it's going to be discharged to
the environment is not part of the
plumbing code preview
they deal with the mechanics of the
sizing they deal with the mechanics of
how it's plumbed just like they do if
you're putting a well tank in your house
that's what the plumbing code does in
the building code
but when you get to the world of
wastewater discharge
that is not in any way shape or form in
the purview under a building code
towns in their building code can have
stricter
excuse me
stricter regulations but they have to
meet the minimum standards of what's
statutorily approved by statute and rule
under rsa 485.
okay um mr just mr sherman can you
help
with this i mean is it true that the
building could
the problem is it seems that
there are issues that
um
you know both involve the building code
and maybe some things that ds has
authority over that's not part of the
building code and
how can this
get sorted out
[Music]
give us some time to talk about it
a grease interceptor automatic grease
removal device shall be required to
receive the drainage blah blah blah blah
blah in food preparation areas such as
restaurants hotel kitchens hospitals and
on it goes so clearly the plumbing code
addresses this issue
des may well
flush things out in more detail and have
operational procedures that are not part
of the of the plumbing code they take a
fairly broad swath at this and say if
you're running a restaurant you're
probably going to have a grease trap
unless somebody proves otherwise
and then they have the tables and the
sizing and all the stuff that goes in
there so that's why i think we need to
to buy some time
for the various departments to work with
us to zip these rules together
it may well be
that that the end game says take this
stuff out of the plumbing code by
amendment and just say go follow the des
rules that's one option the other option
is to bring the particulars of the des
rules into conformance with the model
code
that all needs to be talked about right
now but let me um
explain what i'm thinking about doing
and i would like to do today is you know
have discussion and questions to
hopefully make sure we understand what
the issues and you know are and what
needs to be discussed i i certainly
support um
you folks getting together and and
trying to sort this out and coming back
with a kind of a joint recommendation
so i'm not planning on doing a final
recommendation report today
what i'm thinking is we'll come back
sometime in september
but i'd like to continue this a little
more today just i don't want a situation
where i'd like to avoid anyway a
situation where
um there are issues that
you know between everybody involved
that haven't been brought up so at least
we have a handle on on what we need to
do uh before the next meeting
representative aaron thank you so but
the one of the things that bothers me
or concerns me is the fact that
none of the waste water coming out of
this esta this particular establishment
was evaluated at all
an inspector came in and said you just
need a thousand gallon grease trap and
that was it
so there was no
there was no real um
investigation or
uh
um you know looking at what
the the factors are that were involved
here
it was just
a dictate given to a business to do
something
because that's what was in your rule
there was no uh you know
they didn't check
the the septic grease uh you know the
filter at all they didn't look at they
didn't look at anything they just came
in and said well you don't have this so
you have to have it
and
and that's one thing that really
concerns me with all of this
so penny would like to respond
yeah thanks for the question
representative aaron i think the issue
being is is number one
first of all we don't have the staff to
run around every restaurant in the state
that has a grease trap to see what
they're
to sample their discharges
secondly we know from past experience
and i've been around
a long time that if we're coming to
inspect something and practices many
times and i'm not throwing spears at
baldur's arrows
changed because we're going there to do
some water quality sampling
the bottom line is when you get in a
situation and you have the basic
premises
of
appliances if you will that are going to
have a large potential to generate
wastewater which in fact is going to
come out of that structure
and go
to the ground waters of the state
then i think the the conservative
approach is is this is what you have you
got prior ladies you got a 180 degree
dishwasher you've got this you've got
that the potential is there that could
sell that property tomorrow somebody
could come in and have a total different
protocol of how they run their
restaurant the bottom line is is that
we're responsible
for ensuring that when wastewater is
generated from any building whether you
own it today and bob comes in tomorrow
and buys it and has total different
strategies on how they want to run that
kitchen
so in the long term the viability of
discharge is always going to exist in
that system
so in fact we go and look at the
conservative approach
here's the potential that is generated
because of the appliances i just talked
about
and that's how that happened when this
particular facility got a septic system
approval there was no indication there
was going to be
grease traps fried food
this that and the other thing so that's
where this came about i will grant you
and phil has talked to our inspectors
that when we get in a situation like
this that maybe we have a lot
more in-depth dialogue
about where we're going
and i would concur with what you said i
said it's
i would like to think that our staff
would be a little more accommodating but
it doesn't sound like they might have
been
which i apologize for if that's the case
but
i just want you to know that we're not
looking to be
bureaucratic at its best
what we're looking for is our
assignment not commitment
to make sure that whenever we discharge
wastewater to the state's public trust
groundwater that in fact we do diligence
on
ensuring that in the long term
what is going to be discharged out of
that facility whatever it may be
is not going to be a detriment to the
overall environment of new hampshire and
the state's groundwater
i if i may i can appreciate
that
view
but by the same token
um
if somebody were to buy this
establishment and do something different
with it wouldn't you
before you license them look at that
system again
i mean
you'd have to give them some sort of
license or
okay to do whatever they're doing or
whatever they propose to do
okay well
that's a good question and i think keep
in mind that we don't license the
operation of running a restaurant what
we do do is we permit
the structures ability
to discharge wastewater
if hhs goes in they have food inspectors
that go throughout the state who
actually issue a food service license
if in fact
and they've had a lot of turnover like
we have all had in government
if they go out and
the new folks aren't asked the right
questions or know what to look for they
may very well get a food license
but let me be very clear we do not
license the operation of a restaurant
we permit
the structures ability whether it be a
restaurant child care
residential commercial whatever
we permit the right
for them to generate
to discharge the generated wastewater
for whatever that facility is going to
produce
and
i will say for the record that
we certainly are experts in grease traps
we know what happens if grease traps
aren't maintained
we've seen it
we've experienced in the last two or
three years some real concerns about
greece
we've had a lot of people that are going
into malls shopping centers
leasing space unbeknownst to the people
that own the on-site waste water system
put in a restaurant put in high-temp
dishwashers 12 months down the road
we get a plan come in because the septic
systems fail and you know why
it's because that system was never
designed adequately
to handle a grease load that now is
coming out of that structure
so who pays for that
the guy that least
unsuspectingly to the land so
it's
our
experience has been
that
greece
is a detriment
it's as much of a detriment to the
people that own the system is it is
potentially to the environment if in
fact it blows out
and
so
i mean that's my plea
i i don't know what more to tell you
i feel pretty comfortable that that our
rules do not conflict and we could get
the ag's opinion if you'd like on that
with the building codes
two separate entities to different
worlds that we deal with we have the
expertise to determine strength of
wastewater what it's going to discharge
and how it's handled
if somebody wants to install an interior
grease trap in the plumbing
then they have plumbers they have
building codes that they have to follow
for that installation
oh sorry then if they did i'm sorry yeah
no go ahead if you have a follow-up but
then if
so if this establishment put in an
interior grease trap
you would not have permitted them though
yeah if they came to us and requested a
waiver and told us that they had a high
temp dishwasher they had triolators
they had
other
ways to create and generate grease
you're probably right
okay but
in this particular instance they have
one fry later
okay
and they have i don't i don't know what
their dishwasher is at all but the the
amount of grease coming out of this
business is minimal if you really take a
look at it
i mean so to require them to put in this
massive grease trap
exterior to their building
seems to be total overkill and
i
i'm concerned about that for other
businesses who
you know
who may may have an interior grease trap
and nobody cares or nobody does anything
about it
so i i just it just seems common sense
to me
to
if we're going to go into the situation
of permitting these businesses to have
and nobody wants greece in the
environment nobody wants to have
a situation where even the the the
septic hauler won't accept their
materials because
they're in contaminated with so much
grease or whatever
we all understand that we don't want the
environment to be harmed because of
miss sizing of grease traps
but we want it to be done in a common
sense way that if you have a business
that's minimally
contrib you know
producing grease in their system that
they shouldn't need to be mandated to
put in a system that's totally overkill
for the system that they have
again i i
i'm trying to understand where you're
going with this
but you got to keep in mind that they
are appear to be very good stewards of
the environment
they could that business could change
tomorrow
and what happens
this whole
thought process
we've both been having goes away because
now we have no idea what's going to be
coming out of that structure
it's just like somebody coming to us an
analogy if i might would come in to us
and we get a phone call which is very
common by a building inspector that hey
bob added a fourth bedroom to his house
that would be like i go and talk to bob
and bob says to me well yeah but i don't
have ever plan on having people sleep
there
well bob you know so what are we
supposed to do we have to take the
rational
approach
the conservative approach and say look
if you're going to add the potential
of wastewater another 150 gallons per
day coming out of that bedroom which is
what our flows require then in fact your
system should be designed for it
same thing
different kind of waste water same thing
it's what's being discharged to the
septic system and the environment
and that's where we're coming from
you know if
believe me we don't care
we want people to thrive
but our job is to in fact make sure that
we protect the groundwater and the
surface waters of the state
our rules have i've been at the des for
49 years
i've been through many rule making
processes over the years to see what's
going on
our rules are not
overzealous
i think our experience over my lifetime
at that agency has been that we have
these rules in place because unlike the
people that you're dealing with may not
be
such environmental
stewards
and so what happens with any laws or
statutes that are created
they're created to protect the overall
environment and that's
you know again i want
make it very clear that i'm not making
any accusations about your folks at this
restaurant
they may be very good stewards the point
i'm trying to make is if they walk away
from that structure
next month
and sell it
then we want to have the conservative
approach so we're not worrying about
somebody else coming in
and blowing grease out of that agency
into the environment
but if i may i mean then if if a
business is sold or a house is sold
the the people coming in though would
have the place inspected they would have
to go get uh
so
let me ask a question maybe to clarify
this and that is and then i'll i'll get
to you
um
so if a business is sold i mean it was
permitted as
whatever this was a small restaurant or
or
food dispensing place
and it sold to somebody else does ds get
involved at all in that
no
so there's no permitting that where ds
would look at it again
assume unless there's a complaint would
you ever look at that place ever again
no okay
well that's a very good question i
appreciate it we don't consider
ourselves environmental police which
that would be sort of following say
nothing about i got three compliance
people to cover the whole state for all
water programs but i mean the point
being is and one may say
well people do diligence when they get
property transferred well that is the
furthest thing
i can tell you
from anything
you know how many people buy buildings
buy boat houses buy docks
buy commercial properties that aren't
diligent
and all of a sudden we get a phone call
and they say geez i should have known my
lawyer didn't look at it well the stock
reality of it is here is most transfer
of property
a large percentage of those transfers
have not done diligence it's the nature
of the beast
uh representative schmidt you have a
question
uh thank you mr chairman so
it seems to me like we've got several
issues in play here it's not just this
one situation
and i i was out of the committee room
hearing uh one of my own bills when this
issue came to edna the first time
so i don't know if you've ever walked
into a movie halfway through
he spent the rest of the movie trying to
figure out what the hell was going on
because it wasn't obvious
and at the end you got it completely
wrong because you
didn't have the first half
didn't see that first shot or whatever
so um
but i came in and and this this issue
has
lived in my head
for uh the um
for the entire time since then because
it is a serious issue
to the degree that that the state is
acting with heavy hand or an agency is
acting with heavy hand visa v
a citizen of the state
that's something i don't think that any
of us would want to happen
whether it's a police officer that
misunderstood the situation came in too
late in the movie
misunderstood the situation and arrested
the wrong person
thought that something else was
happening and so forth and so on and the
net effect is harm is done to a citizen
a business whatever
because of a lack of information
so
i'm striving for a perfect world here
renny
uh and uh so
but i've been thinking about this for a
long time because as you know and
maybe the rest of you a couple of my
committee members know i'm on the jail
car and i have been for 16 years so i
see the state agencies coming before me
constantly with regard to rules and so
forth that are supposed to implement
statues so this is the kind of issue
that you've raised representative that's
very troubling because at first glance
in any way it certainly seems
that
the wrong thing was done
but i'm not an expert i'm not a plumber
and i missed the first half of the movie
so i'm not sure i've got all the facts
even now
so
to try to resolve this particular issue
i think it's worth
a little bit of study
to see if we can get a better process so
that state agencies interact better with
customers
and and we've seen bills like this
know a number of times over my 20 years
in the house
where
we're trying to get the state agencies
to work better with our business
community
so that you get
incoming businesses have a more
welcoming and accepting and
understanding reception
and that we don't get the situation
where
the state gets it wrong
and comes down because as they say first
blush this large and i saw the pictures
of this monster grease trap
and heard the story of the the the the
devices that this
former
ice cream store wasn't that what it was
originally an ice cream shop and it
started suddenly
serving fried food
and now they've got a different
situation
and it just didn't seem reasonable to me
so i'm very concerned about this because
i i am also i am always trying
to achieve perfection so this is issue
one and i think it's worth pursuing
uh
the other one of the other issues
certainly is the one that
mr sherman
trowbridge and so forth are talking
about and you're
not disagreeing with that
that we need to
have an interaction of the two agencies
involved the bill mcconnell review board
i've seen you guys in action over the
years uh and yes
uh with regard to this
the the issue of greece
in general
because i have i i'm a city guy
i live in dover my girlfriend lives in
portsmouth so everything we produce goes
into the city sewer system
a very different world from when you're
out in the country
producing something that's going to go
into your into the groundwater or into a
septic system
um
and if and if you overload it you got a
problem
so i'm i'm very disposed to see you guys
have the time to see if our processes in
the state of new hampshire work as well
as they might
one of the aspects that's clearly
involved here
is that we are still a relatively small
state
we have limited resources as even new
york and california do they still have a
limit it's a lot higher than ours
but the question is the resources so
that we
have as many people
to do the work
and that they are as well
trained and
overseen and
provided with statutory and rule
production and so forth so that it works
as well as possible so i my question
believe it or not there's always a
question
is
this
thing that you're
talking about having the time
perhaps to study some other states
processes
to see whether there's something we
could learn from them so we don't have
to invent a wheel by ourselves
that seems like a reasonable enterprise
in itself
but i would also like to see what
we can do about this particular instance
that you've raised
which
as i say where we it seems like
the state came at it heavy-handedly
and you know there was a bill
that that that we in
you didn't have it in you on your
committee but all of us on edna the rest
of us
had with regard to the jail car there
was a bill
that was going to basically completely
rework the gel car
with regard to
rule approval
and that is a major undertaking as you
can imagine those of you who dealt with
a gel car
so i think that
that it may be appropriate to have
some bill go forward
but but
but i don't know that we got the right
language at this point at this time and
i'm sure you know maybe you don't
that this this bill
nothing's happening with it now it's
dead for this session right the only
question is is it coming back next year
and in what form
and i think that there are several
aspects here that and i
i've worked together with with uh
representative leckus a great deal
in the time he's been in on edna and i
know that he's got it not only a
high level functioning intelligence but
a lot of dedication no no honey around
your mouth but uh uh but a lot of
dedication to try to get at
right problems that the state has to try
to resolve them in the best interests of
the people and of the state as well so
moving forward hang on a moment if you
would turn your mic off a moment i
actually
kind of related to this i have a
question from mr uh trumbridge if i'm
pronouncing that correctly you said that
the department um you know has
used his discretion in the application
of the rules
so
the question i mean my question is um
you know given what we were told about
um you know ds goes in and approves
you know sort of some standard function
for the building paying in effect no
attention to what the current owner is
going to do because they're
there they don't know who's going to own
in the future what they're going to do
i mean what circumstances would you use
discretion and is there
in this particular instance presuming
for the sake of argument that
the thousand gallon tank is really
inappropriate and grossly too big for
what they are doing
assuming that i don't know for sure
myself
um you know how would this process of
discretion been applied what would the
business owner have done how would this
all have work because from what we've
been told they were just given this dot
and no indication that there was any way
to do anything else
and and uh
representative schmidt said what to do
about this case well at this point
they've already put the thing in
but it's a matter of okay
you know
assuming
that
you know the things weren't applied
correctly at least for this owner of
this business how could it have been
done
differently and better for this
application
sure um
thank you for the question um
you know we use discretion
with great discretion i guess is a way
to say it
and
we um you know we have the ability to
wave rule but not statute so we clearly
do not do any kind of you know anything
that's in statute we don't
you know we have no authority to change
uh so that's the first question we
always ask ourselves is this in rule or
resistance statute and then
uh for rules we do have
requirements in the in our like in the
rules as you would know representative
schmidt from from jl carr
we have the rule that allows us to wave
rules under certain conditions you know
and those conditions might be that
there's going to be
no harm to the environment no effect on
a neighboring property
et cetera et cetera it kind of depends
on which program you're you're in what
those specifics are
um
and so we're very careful on this you
know for the reasons that um uh mr
pelletier talked about because you know
the extreme cost of a of a failed septic
system or the extreme cost of septage
you know holler not being able to
dispose of their load so we really only
are
waive this rule in cases where you know
we have
um assurances that this building doesn't
have seating i mean a small a small
shack doesn't have seating um but it
doesn't have the grease generating
appliances you know installed or the
capacity for those
um and so in this case you know when it
was just um ice cream it was something
that we felt comfortable with but
um
the switch to the fried food and you
know regardless of how much it was and i
recognize that you know your
your
constituents you know are not you know
they're running it in a way that doesn't
generate much but they are running it in
a way that has the capacity to generate
grease someone else could buy that
business and run it in a different way
and so that's you know tripped the
threshold for us
we we do try to work with people i mean
we recognize that we're public servants
and we're trying to help people achieve
their objectives so we
you know we try and you know we deal
with a high volume of applications so
sometimes you know we are quick in the
response and we could take a little more
time and i'm working with staff on that
um and you know i think that's how it
might be handled differently is just
better explanation
of what we're doing and the reasons why
um
but you know realistically because you
know the generation of
fried foods in this facility right now
we really
you know
we would not have have waived that
that rule
okay thank you uh mr sherman
i
i wonder if i might suggest a path
forward addressing these concerns uh if
as you indicated
you scheduled a meeting in september i
would hope later in september only
because not much is going to happen in
august
and let des bcrb get the proper people
from both groups
the technical experts
to
look at the two sets of rules see where
the overlap is give great sensitivity to
these smaller uh institutions
everybody's heard the concern here
clearly
and come back to you all in september
with at least a conceptual agreement
that
uh if there are rule changes or
amendments to the building code or both
that are necessary that we'll proceed to
get those into the mix
nobody's going to update anything before
then anyway
but i think that will let us get the get
the technical issues in a in a clear
manner in front of us and come back to
you with some some agreement as to where
we think things ought ahead and then see
whether uh that satisfies the need uh i
think we probably do have the right
legislation in place uh there may need
to be rule changes on both sides uh
and and that just needs some study
just a suggestion yeah thank you um that
sounds good i'll hang in just a moment
and um yeah it's it would have to be
later september i'll be traveling the
earlier part of the state anyway
um and the other thing to look at as
part of that is um
whether
you know it might be appropriate to add
a little bit of clarification on 155 a2
roman 10 that we had discussed to see if
because there's actually two parts to it
and one of them
is sort of a little clearer on what it
means i think than the first part but
um we could we can go into that more in
september um
yeah you can respond
i i agree fully uh
that carries over to a much broader
issue with other other agencies and so
forth
whereas this task
through the summer might almost be an
exemplar as to how we could deal with
some of these issues and if we're
successful prove that it can actually be
done and we all come out singing off the
same sheet of music
yeah so you actually in uh
you sent an email that noted that there
were a number of other departments that
had
put in place rules that might impinge on
the
purview of the state building code
review board and i think you mentioned
in a general sense some of them if you
could
you know
get any more specifics to me that would
be um
helpful
and uh because at least that statute
change would be and have an impact on
all of those um representative bailey
had a question
yes um i i like your idea mr sherman of
getting together and coming up with
something because this should never have
happened and it should never happen
again
and as far as i'm concerned i would vote
for anything
scaling right up to eliminating your
department to make sure this never
happens again so you need to come up
with something to make sure that this
would never happen
anybody else who has uh
representative fellows
yeah i have
a couple of i i think we need to hear
from health and human services also
because i think they're approving
the the restaurants in the and so i i
think they're part of the puzzle here
but i also just have two technical
questions i just want to know what does
isds stand for
and
there's a reference to gravity grease
inceptors so if somebody can tell me
what is a gravity one and what are the
kinds that are something other than
gravity
yeah please respond if you can
thank you for the question the first
question is ists individual sewage
disposal system so it's it's the
technical term for a septic system
um and then the gravity
with onsite wastewater we always
distinguish between gravity-fed systems
and ones that need pumps so a gravity
fed there's no
mechanical pumps involved it you know
the water flows downhill through the
system just by gravity um and then but
you have circumstances where someone
needs to actually pump
something to another location and that's
the distinction
what are the other kinds other than
gravity
or well it has a well
aren't there i thought that the grease
what i saw on the internet had to do
with things like some of them sit
underneath like the sink
in the kitchen and then but you
the ones that you're talking about are
outside the building is that seems that
that seems like two very different
things to me uh this sorry i may have
misunderstood the question so a sign of
gravity there's you know gravity systems
for septic systems almost all say all
grease traps operate on the basis of
gravity which is just
density separation of fluids so that you
you have a
a container big enough
that the flows can can
have a residence time of of days so that
the oils and grease can float to the
surface and separate from the water and
then the outlet of that of that
structure is below the layer where the
grease is
so that the you know the water is going
out and the grease is staying in
anything else or so
when you have that they all have that
whether you put them outside or inside
they all work in that same principle
yeah they all so what happens when
there's too much
grease that's why the um then the the
grease will would exit
this grease trap it would not be an
effective trap and then it would go into
the septic system
and that's where we get the failure
problems
and so when i was mentioning earlier
about you know the pump out rates
uh and the frequency of that that it all
has to be connected so that you are
pumping it out frequently enough so you
don't get too much grease
doesn't it get like clogged up and the
water doesn't even go down uh
no if it liquid grease this is normally
not not like a solid fat but like a
liquid grease would just be washed out
with the water and that
that then clogs up the
the soil pores in the septic system does
it does an alarm go off or something how
would you know
no it does not and that you know that's
you know i guess part of the the
rationale of these larger requiring
these larger tanks is because they're
more foolproof
but they can get clogged they do the
same thing right yes but they are they
they're they don't need to be pumped out
as frequently
and they okay
so yeah so if you need
a trash can size scent thing
but if you buy put in a
thing the size of a swimming pool
it's going to last a lot longer before
it
fails correct
right and i uh having uh dealt with my
own septic system for almost 40 years um
i you're talking about backing up i mean
if you get enough grease out of the
leech field and the leech field clogs up
enough then things would either either
back up or the stuff would be bubbling
up
your leech field which isn't good um
but yeah the restaurant has to have the
grease trap emptied periodically even if
it's working correctly
because it builds up
let's let's not lose fact
let's track of the fact that what we
heard in testimony at the time was that
zero grease
went into the septic system
that the guy
pulled it out and sold it down the
street and zero was going in there so
all this talk about all the different
levels of water and grease the
separation it's all just nonsense in
this case
he should have had a variance
and we can talk all we want about septic
systems and isds and all this but it
does not apply
that there was zero grease in this case
representative uh aaron thank you mr
chair yes so i have a question to for
you what
is
what are the problems that you can
encounter with an oversized
grease trap system i i'm understanding
that
putting in or installing an improper
sized grease tank
aside from being a waste of money
could cause an unsanitary situation
where you have odors you have bacteria
growing you have um you know sort of
that also can create an unsafe situation
is that not the case
that would be the case for an in the
building grease trap not for a septic
tank
okay any other questions
uh anybody else
the public here who'd like to speak on
this
okay um
so thank you for offering to get
together and try and come up with uh
hopefully some way of uh
dealing with there's actually a few
issues one is
is there any kind of a a conflict
between um
155 a 2
and what ds is doing as far as an
overlap of
um you know the ds rules and whether or
not they were
passed by and approved by the building
code review board and you folks can talk
about that and come back with
you know your your take on it and any
recommendation
the other one i'd look for is um
you know is there any way to have dealt
better with a situation like this again
presuming that
they really didn't need anything even
close to this this thousand gallon
grease trap it would have been a better
way to handle this
and then uh
you could also discuss the 155 a2 the
larger issue of
where there's
departments creating rules that might
impinge on what's in the building code
and uh
you know
is there something that we can do about
that either require statute or at least
maybe when the rules get get renewed i
mean if that's true then presumably if
they went through normal rule making
those rules would have gone to jail car
and if there is such a
a situation where they're creating rules
that should have been reviewed by the
building code review board but we're not
that somehow that wasn't caught and
maybe
you know the staff on gel core or the
members on it could be
keeping a little closer eye out for that
particular issue for the future when
rules get renewed
uh representative fellows i i'd be
interested to to know what um the
regulations related to greece are for
food trucks
okay that's interesting i don't
presume they keep in the truck and
discharge it somewhere yeah they they're
they're kind of trucks that drive up and
they're selling for
they're historically not connected to a
wastewater discharge
what they do with it when they leave the
site god only knows
but they don't pull up in park and go
into a septic system generally they're
usually self-contained kind of like an
rv
i don't regulate food trucks
because it doesn't put it directly in
the ground officially right so
what i might suggest uh mr chair is that
you know what we're talking about here
is
that you gotta talk
and that this is actually being recorded
and people out youtube land or whatever
can view this now and in the future if
they like i think uh what i'm gonna do
from to
try and respond to the questions about
perhaps conflicts
is i think because i'm an attorney by uh
engineer by trade not an attorney
but i think what
what maybe phil and i can do is ask the
ag
here's 155 he has 485 here's the rules
is there a conflict because i think it
truly is a legal question
not so much you know if you were to put
me in a room and
ask me legally if our rules conflicted
with 155 i'm not sure i'd feel
comfortable in answering that should i
think
uh the ag certainly could so having that
legal opinion is good i'd also like to
suggest that um
even if technically
some of these rules didn't have to be
reviewed by the building code review
board
at least passing it by them
for review even if it's not
officially required and you can put them
in place without that
might be a good idea because it might
bring up potential
conflicts even if they're not legally
technically conflicts and avoid some
problems in the future
one thing i'd like to ask is
for you folks i'm going to put a piece
of paper up there if you can write your
name
phone number and an email
and um you know so i can let you know
when there's going to be a future
meeting
and um
is one of you or all of you going to uh
contact me and let me know um when you
have
what your suggestions are and uh when
you have them so maybe we can take a
look at them before the meeting
all right well i'll expect something
and thank you for uh
if there's nothing else anyone else want
to say anything
um if not thank you for coming here and
helping us try and figure out what to do
with this
and um
once
if you and then the other thing is for
the people that want to be involved we
need to be involved
if you know what your schedule in the
latter part of september is
and there's times you can't be available
if you let me know i'll try and work
around it so send me an email
all right thank you uh this i will
bring this subcommittee work session on
house bill um 1312 to a close thanks
everybody
you